we are celebrating all things design and
that includes
yes cause i love design it makes me
happy
and uh that includes the history behind
some of our favorite styles i mean who
could forget the
geometrical art deco of the 20s or the
groovy colors and shags of the 70s
you heard me hashtag shag but nose style
has had more lasting power
than mid-century modern a look
so iconic it never goes out of fashion
in fact take a look at the history of
this
endlessly chic trend in this design
backgrounder
mid-century modern design began in you
guessed it the middle
of the 20th century the end of world war
ii created an economic boom that allowed
more americans to buy homes
progress in physics chemistry and even
science fiction
resulted in new materials like plywood
fiberglass and
foam used to create innovative designs
with
really vibrant colors people wanted to
move away from the gloom of the war
and embrace both the naturalism and
experimentation
in design the future is now as the
american dreams became more accessible
architects and designers embraced a
populist message
design should be beautiful functional
efficient and attainable branching
across
generations mid-century modern design
has been seen in our homes as well
as on our television screens from the
brady bunch to the jetsons
and to the incredibles and mad men we
have an enduring image
of how our favorite characters lived in
this style
the mid-century modern aesthetic is
characterized by clean lines
simplicity and bright colors pop art and
the space age
both seen as symbols of a modern
futuristic era
help define the look of furniture and
architecture itself and no wonder
that mid-century modern design is still
popular
in the 21st century the timeless style
never seems to lose traction with many
furniture designs
more popular now than they even were
back then in the 50s and 60s
fitting seamlessly into our modern day
mid-century design
was a prediction of our future and is
now
a stylist conversation with our past
i love that it's such an amazing and
rich history for something
so beautiful and so timeless
you